so we're told that mount everest is 29
029 feet tall
estimate mount everest's height by
rewriting it as a number in the form
x times 10 to the white power feet
where x and y are single digit numbers
so let's think about how we would do
this so x and y have to be single digit
numbers so this is if we were to write
in scientific notation we could write
something like let's see it would be two
point nine zero
two
nine
is that right two point nine zero two
times
ten and actually be careful times i
should write like that times
ten
i'll use this little carrot sign i'm
pressing shift and six to get the carrot
sign
times 10 to the and i moved the decimal
let's see in order to go from two to in
order to go from two to twenty thousand
i have to add one two three four zero so
times ten to the fourth so that's what i
would do if they were just asking us to
write it in scientific notation but
they're not asking us to write in
scientific notation they're saying
estimate mount everest height
by writing it in this form where x and y
are single digit numbers
so as i wrote it right over here 2.9029
is not a single digit number four is a
single digit number so at least i got
the y part right but i need to write
this part which you know in this form
this would be the x i need to write that
as a single digit number and the key is
that they want me to estimate so if i
were to estimate 2.9029 i would write
that as 3.
so i'm going to go with 3 times 10 to
the fourth and if i were to expand out 3
times 10 to the 4th it would be 30 000
feet so my estimate seems pretty good so
let's check
there we go